hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to 7 days to die with
my good buddy
Lord minion 777 good day hey guys hello
and we are back with a new game because
we had just a ton of trouble recording
this again um there were surfer issues
there were audio issues there were Skype
issues teamspeak everything we tried
didn't work but we finally got something
up like it's got duct tape and a crowbar
sticking out of its ass and but it's
working so what we got now is a
different server with ten minute day
cycle in that five minutes is in the day
and five minutes is at night so that we
can try our best to show you our
survival skills frustration G and really
else and really try to make this
something hey I found a flashlight is
that good wait I killed a deer no
flashlights kind of stuck no somebody
told me in the comments that if you use
a flashlight in a building dad slows
down zombies like it was daytime oh yeah
like the torches do you mean yeah
because it during the day or at night in
a dark building zombies will run around
like it's nighttime yeah yeah yeah so
that's what I heard did you kill this
deer I did no murderer
oh I don't care it's food for where did
you go oh you're back on the road okay
so like we said it's a five it's a
10-minute day cycle which means that we
do not have a lot of time and in all
likelihood we're probably gonna have to
straight run Oh from the time it gets
tonight to the time it gets today and
it's just gonna be panic screaming with
our heads cut off we don't know what's
gonna happen but we're gonna try to
survive as long as possible and we're
getting good at this we've actually been
playing for a bit now and we work well
together right Wade we were great was I
get us to survive and you get bad ideas
to get us killed hey come on I'm I'm
trying when we went outside and I
chopped all those Dom's up in the face
we went out which was a terrible idea no
we worked it really did work and then
the other time we died but that was
besides the point and that wasn't
recorded on camera so don't worry about
any of that right Wade there was a time
we tried the 5 min
it cycles by the time you got into the
game I'm sorry haha why you didn't you
didn't like that panic screaming I mean
I and you like her world over the game I
think that's what makes us great and
what stands us apart like favorite
comment and subscribe if you believe
that we're gonna be better than anyone
else or if you want to see quality
gameplay of this just check me out yeah
whatever no we're actually gonna try so
I we've been collecting everything on
this road um we're going towards the
neighborhood's here are we gonna hold up
in the neighborhoods because go to the
farm yeah let's go to the neighborhood
that's easier it's like the first step
and it's about to be night because it's
already five o'clock if you don't know
there is a clock behind my face but
there really is nowhere else I could put
our webcams to uh not tied that because
yeah wait is over on the other side
occupying that space with this beautiful
face
and on - the opposite I usually put mine
on the opposite side but with both of us
it's just best having both on top yes
very true very true so anyway I got to
the neighborhood wait what house would
you like uh pick your favorite color oh
gosh I don't know they're all so
beautiful I don't think I could decide
light blue right a friend I don't like
the light blue I like the great you like
you either
well why are we trying to survive
together mister schrick haha shrink like
you do it for blah ro
I said blue and you're going to green
yeah because I said I like green this is
yellow I can't tell it is it's green ish
the way this blah role even in the in
was that one one that ones we failed at
I don't think I believe blah okay
long story short comments mentioned him
so he had to been talking are you sure
because it's all blurring together we've
been trying to get this work for so long
okay brick herb lick what actual you
blink I think I called you Glick cuz I
mix you up a bit of anchorman I call me
brick hahaha brick tumblin that movies
coming out soon by the way we have no
wood to block this we have wood I got
I'm god oh the fan fiction wait I've got
wood it and I'm gonna lock off east no
no don't don't hurt that what
let it go stay
everyone should draw a fan art of us
snuggling on a bed since day one with
you I don't even know what shipping is
to this day you don't go on tumblr and I
I do but I don't really follow anyone
that talks about this thing I got you
yeah I gotcha
you have no Google no Archie mash what
have you googled Marky mash no oh are
you in for a treat Google Marky mash
when do you get a spare chance everybody
watching do not Google Marky Marky I've
known you long enough to where I don't
want a Google Marky mess
why not what could possibly be the harm
um despite what's going on the live
stream I don't actually enjoy when you
just randomly lift your legs come on why
you see Leonard can you are you up here
yeah I'm up here I'm blocked off the
stairs what are you doing all cows in
the Attic are you in the Attic Oh
something's in my eye again with the
burning it's always happened I don't
know why aren't you I'm punching these
stairs so I can we can get more Kiron
punching the f out of this bird's nest
there's literally something in my eye
and they're tears streaming down my face
but I still caught something is in your
eye just though they can punch through
the floor and take you down to the next
level
ah that doesn't sound good since one
will do this yeah okay then let's go up
to the attic okay all right it's not
very exciting up there I don't care I
found a submachine gun okay I literally
have tears streaming down my face but my
journalistic integrity allows me to
continue with my perfection sob wide if
I have journalistic integrity I'm gonna
use it to the best of my ability and you
can shut your dingdong damned flytrap so
that we can all get some peace and quiet
there's something hanging out of your
characters all you're holding would what
is what are you trying to say what
looked like you were taking a lie with
you floor what are you trying to say
that there was always got a nice
close-up of me crouching the side check
out waves channel for the uncensored
versions version the darkest would call
it oh my would yes please please
you're just Fanning the flames what I
heard glass break was up yeah I think
those downstairs I have a submachine gun
you make torches I have cloth here I'll
drop it for you to take torches and
here's some wood so that you can get how
do i drop wood
q there we go yeah yeah I got it there
you would have dropped okay so make
torches I got the defense I guess oh
it's still a very disconcerting give you
this rifle it's not in good shape
oh it's actually a shotgun and then
there's shotgun shells I've got a pistol
right now uh well you you with you want
the submachine gun ammo I just threw it
on the ground yes please where to go see
you see this viewers cooperation yeah
deliberation supplicate emancipation
proclamation sublimation is the purest
by which ice goes to a gaseous state or
a solid ghost food gaseous state ice was
just an example that's right isn't that
sublimation I think so
I am correct porches I went to school
and stuff thank you sir you are being so
helpful for me our cooperation other
schemes here's the crap out of me I do
want to live in this game actually is
quite nerve-wracking you I was playing
nether and I was losing my mind on that
one cuz I was just so dang nervous about
everything
okay I'll put one on the out of the
house there we go good enough uh maybe
not good enough I don't see any zombies
out here that's good good it's almost
daytime to see me wait uh wait up dear
there did you push me out of the house
did not push you away right oh okay I uh
I don't think they're on the second
floor just yet so I'm gonna go in here I
made a ladder what where oh no what
huh we're either up here where would you
make a ladder you break down wood into
wood planks than you make sticks oh okay
so you like yeah I don't you just put in
like a okay alright still like Minecraft
in that sense alright you know as soon
as day breaks we're gonna break in we're
gonna split up go to the other houses
loot as much as we can
it got it do you need it in water I got
lots of water um actually yes here I
want apparition between me and Wade we
love each other cuz we're great people
that watched rope Minecraft actually
don't believe that you and I get along
like this ever
what haven't they seen our livestream
well yes I met message and asked if I'd
if you forced me to go out to lunch and
stuff with you I just hold it in - but
yes yes that's how much they think we
don't get hope how low would your
self-esteem have to be that I bully you
into getting lunch just because I'm
lonely I like the bar make you go and
pay for my lunch give me your lunch
money
Wade Oh Gardevoir get over oh man all
right we're good it's Fela you look down
you go the other way I kill these
zombies that are in our house oh there's
zombies it well we probably shouldn't
use that house as our primary base of
operation maybe later
okay found another shotgun canned food
what are we looking for in terms of
craftable x' because i know that we want
to aren't diving into like the more
deeper elements of this I know in order
to build like a good farm you need to
build on the second floor you can't lead
one on the ground from what I've been
able to do okay so I was gonna build a
second-story yeah and we need like stone
crafted into cobblestone to be supports
for that okay got it
the rocks that are around the trees
outside yeah all those rocks no matter
what size there turn into one stone
block and four stone blocks makes four
cobblestone block okay all right I got
you like lots of stone
lots of wood food water okay alright
then you focus on the stuff in the
houses I'm gonna clear out this house
and then go out into the woods and
you'ii need stone and wood right so what
I wanted work alright that's what I'll
get any scrap metal that you find and
I've got a lot of scrap metal here's a
dead body
excuse me as I take your pills I hope
they're happy pills because you don't
look very happy they're probably not
happy pills they're probably not happy
probably probably really bad we denied
them dinner last I just pushed this uh
whole bed in my pocket and I am out the
door
bloody freaking dah I think the dogs
hear me the most ha ha those poochie's
are not messing around buddy
ok I'm punching the dart just like you
taught me Wade that's good it's like you
taught me
uncle way deep ooh good people nephew
wow it's afternoon already we do not
have a lot of time do we offer no where
are the 5 minute cycles
yeah or 10 minute day cycle 5 mates like
day and night cycle though so it's
likely speaking I believe that there is
much more daylight than there is night
in this part of the hemisphere because
if you know your geography in the globe
and the way it works then you know that
the this is the Earth orbits the Sun at
an angle and here we go
oh god this is gonna be difficult ok all
right everybody bear with me I'll
Arkansas the rivers this quit light
everybody shut up I'm trying to explain
everybody shut up I'm trying to science
the angle of the axis of rotation of the
earth allows for the Sun to hit a
portion of the hemisphere depending on
where you are in the world more than it
would in different parts of the world so
if you were in the northern hemisphere
and the angle was tipped in that
direction then as it's rotating around
the Sun in a certain season there would
be more Sun exposed to a certain side of
it in that hemisphere because of the
angle ergo either Sun can or day can
last longer or shorter depending on both
the season and the location of yourself
on the hemisphere that is why in some
places days lasts for six ladka like
Alaska huh I just science I am going to
take a break and go back to derp please
derp with me Wade well we have like a
minute left of daylight I'm getting a
lot of wood huh are gonna wood in my
pants hahaha your mom shotgun oh I
wonder if these bullets taste good
ha ha ha let's get ourselves killed
repeatedly Oh markiplier and his natural
decision yes is there beautiful yet
terrifying sight to see markiplier ok it
three here are you being the narrator
from Sponge Bob uh
bikini boat it that was very good I was
that your wait was that what you were
going for because he'll determine
whether I am proud of you it wasn't
originally actually it sounded just like
it like no joke it was right on spot on
there anyway I got a lot of wood um I
got some stone I couldn't actually I
need to go find more stone um oh dear me
I was just focusing on the wood and then
I was explaining science and it was not
good for multitasking cuz you know a lot
of people think that we're exceptionally
stupid but in reality we're both very
educated and rather highly intelligent
individuals we got college degrees to do
nothing I don't have a college degree
but that's another story
oh we you were a biomedical engineer I
was a biomedical engineer and then other
things came up extra that is a long
story um you can check out actually my
draw my life for part of the reason why
that and the other reason is that I
started doing YouTube so yeah what's the
house we go on tubes it's like it's it's
sleepy night time yeah yeah yeah I'm
collecting wood earth stones I'm putting
my rocks in wood I'm in the white house
second one I'll stay on the mat okay I'm
coming now because apparently it's night
like right now and I'm out of strenght
juice I'm coming
no let me Oh made the doors even open
still you're good okay all right I'm in
here okay so let's uh oh you're outside
are you outside I'm not I'm just oh whoa
okay all right I'm gonna board this up
you have the wood good plan okay I'm
gonna board this up and then we're gonna
cut the episode cuz we are out of time
for this one
well it's good if you guys I'm sure that
you guys like the faster day/night cycle
it keeps things interesting and keeps us
active for the most part yeah so we are
all out of time check out White's
channel for his POV and other insights
into the intricacies of get up in the
static Wade get up and what get him in
the Attic I'll get up in the attic get
all ecstatic and I get an example static
would get a Wallace Dennis so make sure
you don't watch it go anyway thank you
all so much for watching check it like I
said check out Wade channel I've already
cleared the South by the way with don't
and what
we'll see you in the next video I messed
up that outro but but I yeah giant porn
flick it's not like your pork was my big
I'm saying literally your porn
collection is all about giant just big
Amazonian tribes yeah you can never go
wrong with the venom a yeah though kinds
that can crack your skull open between
their five what is it
they giant end the muscle oh they're
giant in terms of hole they're like nine
feet tall
I've seen your click it's very scary I
would never go out with a woman that
could actually just beat here